this video is kindly sponsored by
brilliant the place to improve your
skills in science maths and computer
science
what do you think is the largest threat
the atmosphere poses to you right now as
in how would the atmosphere be most
likely to kill you
climate change
hurricane storm drought
the answer is
none of those things by quite some
distance the world health organization
estimates that seven million people die
every single year due to
air pollution and let's put that number
in context on this graph what do you
think these other causes of deaths per
year are compared to air pollution if
you guessed terrorism war
road accidents and obesity you'd be
right
according to the world health
organization air pollution kills 70 as
many people as all cancers combined and
it's worth noting that other
organizations estimate the death toll to
be even higher now you may be hearing
this and thinking well this is a problem
for low-income countries statistically
if you're watching this video you're
from a high-income country and perhaps
think that this isn't a problem that
affects you but guess on this graph
where you think people are exposed to
what the world health organization
determines to be high levels of air
pollution deep red would indicate the
majority of the population of a country
while yellow would indicate a low
proportion go ahead guess perhaps you're
expecting to see a cluster of red
countries in west africa southeast asia
you know big population centers with the
rest being yellow well how about
95 of the world's population is exposed
to mean annual levels of air pollution
that exceed world health organization
guidelines this isn't a low-income
country problem
this
is a global problem
so what is air pollution how does it
affect us
and how can we fix this problem firstly
it's important to draw a distinction
between indoor and outdoor air pollution
my house doesn't have a fireplace
sorry indoor air pollution is caused by
the burning of solid fuels such as coal
charcoal wood even dung for cooking and
for heating indoors quite obviously
doing so fills the air with soot with
carbon monoxide with various other
compounds and especially in poorly
ventilated spaces that has a huge impact
on respiratory health but solid fuels
are predominantly used in lower income
countries as a country economically
develops it tends to phase out the
indoor use of solid fuels in favor of
more expensive but cleaner natural gas
and electric systems for heating and for
cooking as billions of people have been
lifted out of poverty in the last few
decades the number of deaths due to
indoor air pollution have plummeted from
approximately a hundred deaths per 100
000 people in 1990 to just over 30
deaths per 100 thousand in 2019
unfortunately however over the same time
period the death rate from outdoor air
pollution has stayed the same
why outdoor air pollution is a different
beast to indoor air pollution instead of
being caused by one type of fuel being
burned for basically two purposes its
sources are diverse and while it's
comprised of multiple different
components in the air its impact on
health can be summarized by just one
particulate matter in simple terms
particulate matter refers to liquid
droplets and tiny solid particles
suspended in the air we categorize them
by size with coarse particles being
between ten and two and a half microns
across and fine particles being less
than two and a half microns in diameter
coarse particles are largely formed from
natural processes dust from deserts and
seafoam but they're also created through
some man-made processes too like dust
kicked up from roads they aren't exactly
good for you they can get deep inside
your lungs and cause problems but
they're not the real troublemakers those
would be the fine particles being mostly
droplets of things like sulfates
nitrates and ammonium ions less than two
and a half microns across fine
particulate matter when breathed in can
penetrate the lung barrier and enter the
blood system in 2016 58 of all premature
deaths caused by outdoor air pollution
were due to coronary artery disease and
stroke both caused by fine particulate
matter even in low concentrations small
particulate pollution has been shown to
not only take years off people's lives
but also have a large effect on quality
of life while they're still living it's
described as the world's leading
environmental health risk factor this
again is a global problem so fine
particulate pollution is the deadly
component of outdoor air pollution but
what creates it what do we need to
remove in order to potentially save
millions of lives every year and why am
i talking about it
the answer is pretty much one word
combustion
fine particle pollution is like coarse
particle pollution a mix of natural and
man-made particles the majority however
comes from humans burning stuff
specifically burning fossil fuels coal
oil and natural gas remember how earlier
i said that as countries economically
develop they've reduced their death rate
from indoor air pollution by not burning
solid fuels those countries power their
economic development by burning more
fuel overall they just do it
outdoors and those countries tend to use
more energy dense fuels such as coal
oil and natural gas which boosts the
economy sure but unfortunately also
boosts the death rate due to outdoor air
pollution
up to a point more on that in a bit wait
a minute the burning of fossil fuels
causing a massive environmental problem
where have i had this before hey i've
seen this one i've seen this one this is
a classic what do you mean you've seen
this
it's brand new in 2019 i was lucky
enough to see former secretary general
of the united nations ban the man ki
moon address a conference on renewable
energy in seoul he gave a powerful
address about air pollution that
ultimately sparked the idea for this
video unfortunately i don't have the
text of what he said in seoul but in
2007 while secretary general he
addressed the commission on sustainable
development saying closely linked to
climate change and energy is the issue
of industrial development over the past
several decades industrial development
has been central to the growth and
poverty reduction achieved in many asian
countries and it remains a leading
aspiration of other developing countries
air pollution is an unhappy byproduct of
industrial development and energy use
energy climate change industrial
development and air pollution are
critical items on the international
agenda addressing them in unison creates
many win-win opportunities the climate
crisis and air pollution are in many
ways two sides of the same coin both
caused by humans burning fossil fuels
and ultimately caused by humans wanting
a higher quality of life perhaps i don't
say this on this channel enough but
people aren't emitting carbon into the
earth's atmosphere for fun or out of
spite they're doing it because they want
a more comfortable wealthier life
and
that needs more energy unfortunately
something that historically has
necessitated the burning of fossil fuels
unfortunately that has caused the
premature deaths of a lot of people
through air pollution the use of fossil
fuels is responsible for between 30 and
40 of the direct disease burden of
outdoor air pollution depending on who
you ask it's estimated that over 3.6
million deaths a year could be prevented
by the direct and indirect impacts of a
phase-out of fossil fuels to put that in
context that's like saving the lives of
everyone in uruguay
every single year and to be clear that's
not even taking into account preventing
the incredibly difficult to quantify
deaths that would occur in the future
with a changed climate due to us burning
fossil fuels at the very least though
we're talking about saving millions of
lives every year but how do we do that
we can't simply tell people to stop
trying to make their lives better or
grow their country's economy humans
should have the right to
self-improvement well the answer lies in
what i hinted at earlier
this graph shows the death rate due to
outdoor air pollution versus the gross
domestic product per capita a metric of
how developed an economy is as economies
develop using more fossil fuels the
death rate increases to a maximum in
middle-income countries and then
decreases in high-income countries
why does this happen because in the last
few decades highly developed economies
have invested in nuclear and renewable
energy generation and electrification of
many processes such as for example
transport this has reduced the burning
of fossil fuels and thus improved air
quality in those countries though as we
saw at the start not to a level that can
be considered safe just yet okay so to
improve global air quality and save
millions of lives all we need to do is
get people to stop using fossil fuels
and get them on board with the renewable
energy transition
right two problems one physical one
practical the physical problem is that
bizarrely outdoor air pollution is
actually helping us in the fight against
climate change you see most of the
polluting particles that are suspended
in the air largely sulfates are
reflecting away some sunlight that would
otherwise reach and warm the earth's
surface the ipcc estimates that these
reflective sulfates cool the planet by
about 0.8 degrees celsius so while the
planet has warmed by about 1.1 degrees
celsius since pre-industrial times if it
wasn't for the reflective properties of
air pollution it would have warmed by
more like 1.9 degrees
so removing those particles from the
atmosphere by not emitting them anymore
is actually going to cause the planet to
warm quite quickly the practical problem
is of course that historically only high
income countries have been able to
afford nuclear and renewable energy it's
all well and good telling a low-income
country that they could save lives and
improve their economy by using solar
power but if coal is cheaper
they're not in a negotiating position
that's their ticket out of poverty
bringing down emissions of greenhouse
gases and saving millions of limes a
year then is a bit more complicated than
just use more renewable energy to
prevent a spike in warming widespread
productions in fossil fuel usage needs
to be matched with similarly rapid
reductions in methane emissions largely
from agriculture and waste management
which would produce a rapid cooling
effect to counteract the rapid warming
effect caused by removing those
reflective sulfates from the atmosphere
studies have
look the science has been done all right
we know what's going to happen this
isn't an excuse to not do this
furthermore while renewables are now
cheaper than coal making them the most
attractive option for new electricity
generation if low and middle-income
countries are going to revolutionize
their energy grids their transportation
networks how their homes use energy
they're going to need money extensive
climate finance from the global north to
the global south is going to be
essential to removing the world's
dependence on fossil fuels and it needs
to be on the agenda at cop27 in egypt
this year and you know we'll go quite
some distance to helping right the
historic wrong that those countries
least responsible for the climate crisis
are the ones most affected by and at
least able to mitigate the effects of it
smells like
sustainable development and for those of
you wondering about nuclear power go
watch my video on why nuclear is
complicated in this context the point
however is that we have a really good
understanding of the world's leading
environmental health risk factor outdoor
air pollution we understand what it is
small particulate matter where it comes
from natural and man-made sources the
latter largely being due to combustion
and how we can prevent millions of
deaths every year rapidly phasing out
the use of fossil fuels
of course it just so happens that doing
so is also exactly what we need to do to
prevent catastrophic climate change this
century as ban the man said tackling
both these global problems at the same
time is a win-win
but what if this was a problem in
isolation what if there were no climate
component of burning fossil fuels and
just
an immense public health problem so
let's say um hypothetically that there
was no climate crisis and that the
earth's temperature is unchanged by our
activities let's say that happens but
the burning of fossil fuels is causing
the air that we breathe to slowly kill
us and that by not acting we are
allowing a country the size of poland to
be killed every single decade
is it moral to not act on this problem
this global problem a global problem
that we know
how to solve
at the start of this video i asked you
what you thought the largest threat the
atmosphere posed to you was and you
probably got it wrong that's because
humans suck i mean generally but
specifically at large numbers we're just
wired to deal with small numbers of
people and relatively simple systems
neither of which are good descriptions
for anything in the modern world to
understand anything on regional national
or global scales which is to say to
understand any system in the 21st
century you need to use statistics and
that's not something the human brain
understands on its own fortunately an
extensive expertly written beautifully
illustrated course on statistics is
available on brilliant who have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant is a
website and app that improves your
skills in maths science and computer
science by introducing you to new ideas
and immediately getting you to apply
them they offer courses from middle
school level to graduate school level
across subjects as diverse as statistics
machine learning and quantum mechanics
crucially brilliant emphasizes that the
objective is to try not necessarily to
be correct
because if you get something wrong then
what happens you just learn from the
experience you improve the next time if
you're in full-time education brilliant
offers an alternative resource to the
classroom shedding light on subjects
from a different angle well if you're in
the big scary adult world
brilliant offers the chance to improve
your scientific thinking and
problem-solving skills and be introduced
to new subjects like statistics to get
started for free visit brilliant.org
simon clark or click the link in the
description and the first 200 people to
do so will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription for themselves or
for a student in their life with thanks
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
and for being well you know
brilliant
thank you so much for watching to the
end i really hope that you took
something away from this video it's a
subject that i really enjoyed delving
into in much more detail than i had
previously and um
yeah as i hope you took away from this
video it's pretty shocking right if
you'd like a recommendation of what to
view next then here's some stuff up here
you can also sign up for brilliant or
subscribe to the channel just below me
and that just leaves me to say thank you
again for watching and i'll see you in
the next one in a different studio this
was temporary